début 2006 les premières tuiles sortait
de ses ateliers la tuilerie de bridoré
était né créé par un homme qui ne se
retrouvait plus dans son métier
précédent mêlant la grande distribution
et l'agroalimentaire hubert de la cote
avait besoin d'un challenge
ce que j'ai voulu faire c'est monté une
entreprise pour me prouver que j'étais
capable de réaliser quelque chose par
moi même quand on est dans une toute
petite entreprise
la moindre erreur est complètement
impardonnable donc on sait le matin
pourquoi on réussit pourquoi on a en a
échoué la tuile doit faire cette large
il vient du département de l'indre elle
est travaillée selon un savoir-faire
exigent la terre est une matière vivante
qui rend la tâche plus difficile qu'il
n'y paraît malaxez mélangé à de l'eau et
du sable
la tuile fini par prendre forme outre le
fils d'hubert de la cote
arthur la tuilerie compte trois salariés
edit décrochant les coupes tous les mets
dans les chics tous les profs je les
mets dans les chariots
là on est en train d'empiler les deux
fils dont qui sont qui sont sèches et
qui vont être destiné à au four donc on
les place sur ce qu'on appelle des
charges on met quatre charges dans le
faux et elles font positionner en
fonction de la couleur que l'on souhaite
avoir
au final après une trentaine d'heures de
séchage les tuiles passeront 24 heures
au four à près de 1000 degrés
la composition de chaque tuile est
strictement identique alors toute la
question est de savoir comment on
obtient de telles différences de
couleurs à partir d'un même matériau
rabassa sa soeur ça se fait avec un
secret professionnel après la la on n'a
pas le droit de pouvoir d'exécution
je peux pas vous le dire il ya plein de
petits châteaux qui sont méconnus qui
tombe à l'abandon et voilà en faisant un
produit qui permet la rénovation comme
est ce que cet effet autrefois elle
arrive à refaire pratiquement ce que les
anciens savaient faire la tuilerie de
bridoré vient d'obtenir le label
entreprise du patrimoine vivant c'est la
50e de ce genre en région centre val de
loire
une récompense gratifiante pour un
parcours hors du commun
le label entreprise du patrimoine vivant
pour nous est extrêmement important
tout cela parce que on a démarré de zéro
la fabrication l'entreprise de
fabrication de tuiles en terre cuite il
ya quinze ans je ne savais pas ce que
c'était qu'une tuile pratiquement
bernard à leonard l'ancien propriétaire
de la tuilerie continue dans l'yonne et
philippe vaucelles l'ancien propriétaire
de la tuilerie de la l'orne à ruffec
château dans l'indre m'ont appris à
travailler et m'ont transmis leur savoir
faire
un manoir en normandie une cathédrale du
sud ouest de la france les projets ne
manquent pas un seul regret pour hubert
de la cote
il n'existe plus d'apprentissage pour le
métier de tuiles y est formé soi même un
futur professionnel demande plus d'un an
la transmission de savoir-faire en et
fragilise